It’s easy to pick the best and worst lines in
Game of Thrones. The true challenge lies in
going through the landfill that is the last two
seasons of the show and trying to find the gems
amidst the garbage. So I’m going to try my best
to pick the “greatest” lines in seasons 7 and 8.
Number 20: “Respect is how the young keep us
at a distance, so we don't remind them of an
unpleasant truth. Nothing Lasts.” So initially
I thought this line was pretty deep and clever,
but then I realized that it doesn’t seem that
realistic. I don’t know anyone who necessarily
distances themselves from old people and this
line kind of shines a negative light on them.
Like sure, they can remind you of the unpleasant
truth of aging. But they also offer so much more
like wisdom that comes from that age. From a more
pessimistic perspective, this line rings true,
so I’ll give it that at least and it’s obviously
better than the absolute mediocrity of the rest
of the dialogue in the later seasons. At least
it made me ponder the meaning of this line to
some degree instead of the dialogue instantly
evaporating from my memory with zero impact.
Number 19: “I know death. He’s got many
faces. I look forward to seeing this one.”
This is just a simple line that I don’t think
needs a lot of explanation. It thematically
gels really well with Arya’s character given
her consistent relationship with the concept
of death. And I like how she phrases wanting to
meet the Night King as him being another one of
death’s many faces. That and Maise’s delivery
of the line is so cool and badass. So yeah,
I don’t think I need to explain
this much further, so let’s move on.
Number 18: “You want a whore, buy one. You want
a queen, earn her.” Ok this may seem like a
controversial pick by even including this line
due to how cringey the delivery of it may be,
but the line itself I think is fine to good.
On one hand, I like the symmetrical structure
of these two lines in the contrast it generates.
Along with it being an empowering line for Cersei
that Lena Heady essentially gives her all since
this is the only decent line of dialogue she
gets all season. But on the other, it feels like
David and Dan are trying really hard to get this
line onto a t-shirt. It seems as though they are
trying to get twitter girls to go crazy over this
line and use it as a mantra or something. Which
I think happened briefly. So because of that,
it kind of breaks my immersion whenever Cersei
says this line, but it made an impact for a
reason. It’s a solid line that’s unfortunately
weighed down by different aspects. It has
the same energy as I drink and I know things
where it seems like David and Dan tried really
hard to make an iconic line. However, I like
Cersei’s line more than Tyrion’s in season 6.
Number 17: “You think our house words are stamped
on our bodies when we're born and that's who we
are? Then I'd be fire and blood too.” This
line isn’t anything special by any means,
but I think it offers a decent counterpoint
to Tyrion and everyone’s perspective of being
prejudiced towards Dany for being a Targaryen.
And the reason why I wouldn’t say this is a good
counterpoint is because it’s not necessarily the
house words but more because she has access to
nuclear weapons. And she’s starting to go off
the rails mentally. That and this line doesn’t
really apply to most houses because they’re
normally positive sayings. But at the very least,
David and Dan actually utilize a literary
device for this line in saying that house
words are stamped onto someone’s body. Which
to me generally elevates lines because literary
devices or figures of speech elevate the
creativity of writing. The first 4 seasons
are filled to the brim with literary devices
like an example being “Your mind needs books
like a sword needs a whetstone.” So in general
literary devices bring lines out of a mediocre
level and imbue them with wit. So that’s kind
of why I’m including this line since David
and Dan’s literary device usage was almost
non-existent throughout the later seasons.
Number 16: “Tell them winter came for house Frey”
Similar to Arya’s last line, this is a simple,
but effective line. The main reason why I’m
including it is because she uses the word
winter over other more generic words like death
or misery. Winter instead is a clever way of
still saying that while also being a thematic word
relating to the Starks. So with this line she’s
essentially communicating in a smart way that the
Starks have taken revenge on the Freys. Again,
this is at 16 because of how simple it is
and I don’t think it can really be higher.
Number 15: “I don’t plan on knitting by the fire
while men fight for me” I think this is a classic
line for Lyanna Mormont. It’s pretty much the
embodiment of her badass persona and communicates
a strong feminist message through this single
line. It’s not elevated by any good wordplay,
but I really like the snappiness of this line
and how it immediately makes lord Glover shut
up. To me, it feels like an empowering line
that instantly changes the opinions of every
lord about whether or not women should fight in
the Long Night. Although, you could also probably
attribute that to lazy writing in that this point
of potential debate ends right away. Everyone just
accepts women having to fight in the great war and
it seems like this could be a point of conflict.
But heyyy, that’s just overall writing and doesn’t
actually affect the quality of this single line.
Number 14: “Sometimes duty is the death of love.”
I feel kind of dirty for even including this line
because it’s essentially cheating on David
and Dan’s part. They literally reverse one
of the best lines in the earlier seasons
and call it a day. But on a technicality,
it is a good line. I’m just not going to put this
line any higher because of how cheap it feels. And
the reason why I’m not putting it lower is because
narratively it actually fits well here. Because
Jon’s duty of needing to kill the mad queen
is inherently the death of love. So in a way,
it’s kind of used literally. Tyrion is
communicating in a smart way what Jon
needs to do to save the realm by reversing
his quote. It works well in this moment,
but this line obviously has the baggage of just
slightly changing up an old hit and re-releasing
it. And even then, I’d still put it over most
other lines of dialogue in the later seasons.
Number 13: “She’s always been good at using the
truth to tell lies” Now this is a good line,
but I really can’t think of that many
examples of Cersei using the truth to
tell lies. She mostly just flat out lies to
people. Or using the truth as a base point
to fabricate lies like what most people do.
Although, they are referring to Cersei using
the truth of her being pregnant and our
heroes expecting her to value her life,
but she lies about helping against the Night King.
So it’s technically true and the reason why I’m
putting this line higher than others is because of
the solid oxymoron. She uses truths to tell lies;
which is an interesting way to phrase that
statement due to those words being opposites.
David and Dan could have communicated this
line of dialogue in a much more generic way,
but I’ll give them credit here that it
works well. Still though, I don’t want
to give them too much credit because it’s an
okay line amongst a bunch of terrible ones.
Number 12: “Thoros isn't here anymore, so
I hope you're not about to give a sermon.
Because if you are, the Lord of Light's gonna
wonder why he brought you back 19 times just to
watch you die when I chuck you over this fucking
wall.” Between a lot of different characters,
I think Sandor Clegane still has some really funny
lines in the later seasons. Now there’s kind of a
balance in that should I be prioritizing whittier
lines that are smarter, or I should I also include
some clever usages of humor. And I think that
balance pretty much rests on the fact as to
how funny the line of dialogue is and how smart
of insult it is. Which to me, I think this line
is pretty much perfect for the hound. His pure
annoyance towards Beric is always fun to watch and
him threatening to ruin his ultimate importance
in the long night by chucking him over the wall
is priceless. I just imagine the Lord of Light
malding in the sky. That and I didn’t even realize
it, but the hound actually uses a hyperbole
by saying Beric was brought back 19 times
when it was actually 6. So that aids the humor
even more. Overall, a classically funny hound
line and I tried my best to pick his more clever
insults instead of him just cursing at people.
Number 11: “Sometimes nothing is the hardest
thing to do” Honestly, I think this is a really
good piece of advice. However, I think Tyrion is
in the wrong for saying it at this point in the
story. Since he’s essentially advising Dany to
let Jon, Ser Jorah, and other important figures
to die. And the army of the dead up until this
point don’t have any countermeasures against
a dragon. So theoretically, Dany should not be
in any danger and it’s really weird how Tyrion
is giving her this terrible advice. But going
back to the actual line, this is something that
Tyrion says that has some form of intelligence
to it. People oftentimes get antsy and will make
blunders if they don’t thoroughly think about
their actions. So doing nothing sometimes can
be very important. Or the option to choose to do
nothing can also be vital in certain scenarios.
It’s just kind of unfortunate that Tyrion is using
it at a completely bad time, although in hindsight
he was technically right since the Night King got
a dragon. So sure, that was the correct decision.
Number 10: “This one’s been killed 6 times and
you don’t hear him bitching about it” In terms
of sheer quality of dialogue, I’d say this is
partially inferior to Sandor’s last quote at
number 12, however, I think this is a genius
insult towards Gendry whinging. It perfectly
highlights the contrast in temperament
of Gendry’s whiny childlike response to
the situation by comparing him to a grizzled
warrior. It stops Gendry dead in his tracks
as he re-evaluates his entire attitude from
a single line delivered by The Hound. It’s
also funny how they are making fun of Gendry
for reasonably being upset for almost dying,
but these men are so badass that he comes
across as a child. Which this line perfectly
captures that dynamic. That and like usual
Rory McCann’s delivery is always immaculate
and you simultaneously feel the savageness
and pure irritation exuding from his voice.
Number 9: “The Lords of Westeros are
sheep. Are you a sheep? No. You’re a
dragon. Be a dragon.” This is technically a
few sentences, but I’ll bundle them together
into one overall line that communicates
a single point. In terms of wordplay,
this is a pretty basic line and comparing
people to animals has been done in the past
and obviously better. But at least David
and Dan use a small ounce of creativity of
calling commoners sheep and Dany a dragon. Which
honestly, isn’t impressive, but the line carries
a lot of weight because of the significance of
its implication. Olenna is trying to convince
Dany to ascend and become her true self and
I think this line is a great conduit for that
point. Along with Dianna Rigg having perfect
line delivery in every scene, she’s in. Which
also probably elevates this line for me. Just her
saying be a dragon alone is iconic and badass.
Number 8: “Kill a few hundred people, they make
you a lord. Kill a few thousand, they make you
king. And then all your cocksucking grandsons can
ruin the family with their cocksucking ways.” I’m
honestly kind of torn on this line. Because the
first half I really enjoy, but the second half I
think is inferior and is still communicating the
same point and I technically should include it. So
addressing the second half first, David and Dan
regularly devolve into the lazy insults of cock
jokes, which utterly lack any creativity. This
is also kind of weird because David and Dan have
written some good insults in the later seasons
and then we have Bronn who is constantly saying
cock every other line. Maybe there’s a weak link
between the two D’s. So Bronn saying cocksucking
grandsons and cocksucking ways I think is a
lazy way to write the line. Besides that though,
I really like the statement that Bronn makes
here. Especially how he phrases his first sentence
in that most of these rich families have been
established from mass carnage and sheer violence.
An example being the Targaryens essentially being
nobodies in Westeros and then they rode in with
their dragons and rocked most of the population.
Then they turned into the strongest house in
Westeros. So I think Bronn raises an interesting
topic through this line and is a good counterpoint
about how Jaime is gatekeeping Bronn from wanting
to become a powerful lord. Even though this moment
is still devoid of logic since the show acts like
there’s no other lords that exist in the reach.
Number 7: “It's my fucking luck I end
up with a band of fire worshippers.”
Now this may not be a juicy insult, but
I absolutely love the sheer irony of this
statement. It’s just really funny to me how
Sandor, a man whose fear in life is fire,
ends up with Lord of the Light fanatics. So this
line I think calls out a funny scenario that you
may not have really been thinking about. There’s
not much else about this line that’s special since
it’s a quick and funny ironic statement, but
heyyy every line doesn’t need to be that long.
Number 6: “It’ll take a while with a sparing
sword” Now I know that quite of few of these
last lines have been leaning towards humor, but
I’d argue that it’s easier to do humor than it
is making intelligent lines with creative usages
of literary devices. But I actually really like
this line from Tyrion and is both a smart way
to ease the tension between him and his brother
and is also pretty funny. For a moment this
single line from Tyrion actually made me think
he was the Tyrion from the earlier seasons. A
character who is quick, sharp, and funny and this
kind of line I think perfectly suits him. It’s
a great response that serves multiple purposes
while also making it seem like Tyrion was actually
himself again, so that’s why I’d put it this high.
Number 5: “The perils of self-betterment” Yeah
this is the most popular good line from season
8 that you were probably waiting for. Although,
honestly, it feels kind of overrated because of
how simple it is and the fact that the statement
made by the line isn’t that deep. But there’s
really not much else competition for good lines
after going through the entirety of seasons 7
and 8 again, so I guess this is the start of
our top 5. But to give the line some credit,
self-betterment in general is an arduous task even
though it may not seem like that sometimes. And
because of this, I think the line is inherently
an oxymoron in that something that’s seen as a
positive can be a peril to go through. Then
from a character perspective, it acts as a
good payoff for both of these characters who have
made massive transformations into better people.
Number 4: “But then Mormont saw them and you saw
them. And I trust the eyes of an honest man more
than I trust what everybody knows.” Initially,
I thought this was a line that Tyrion said in
season 2 episode 2 where Goer Mormont sends
him the raven about needing more men. But
he doesn’t actually say this and it still feels
like I heard this line somewhere else. So since
I’m losing my mind and can’t find a place of
origin then I guess David and Dan actually came
up with it. And if I’m wrong then this line
gets sent down 10 spots. Similar to Tyrion’s
clever and funny remark towards Jaime, this is
a rare later season moment where Tyrion could
be interchangeable with his earlier season self.
Putting your trust in honest people and ignoring
the noise of public knowledge that is sometimes
twisted into being misinformation is actually a
good nugget of wisdom. Honorable people can be
more reliable for information and overall this
is a good and smart Tyrion line. I would
put it much higher if it actually utilized
some kind of figure of speech and David and
Dan tried harder, but at least it was witty.
Number 3: “Give us common folk one taste of
power, we’re like the lion who tasted man.
Nothing is ever so sweet again.” Honestly,
this line completely took me by surprise
because I didn’t even remember that this was
said by Varys. Probably because this scene is
overshadowed by Dany and Jon’s meeting. But
I was kind of dumbstruck that David and Dan
actually used a simile for once. Although I
wouldn’t say it was particularly outstanding
and still wouldn’t crack the brilliance of the
earlier seasons, but heyyyy it’s still good.
The main reason why I wouldn’t put this line
higher is the meaning behind it. It’s a pretty
simple statement of if you give someone power
then they’ll want more of it. Like that’s an
obvious thing that people know and at the very
least the line itself was finally elevated by
a literary device of calling the common folk
the lion the tasted man. So good job I guess?
Number 2: “Incompetence should not be rewarded
with blind loyalty” Varys two for two baby;
back to back lines. Now this line may not
include a strong usage of a figure of speech,
but I think this is a really good line that
is smart, is very in character for Varys,
and exposes a great topic for the nature of
serving kings and queens. Because there are
so many characters that get stuck serving
incompetent kings. Like that’s kind of the
tragedy of Varys in that he’s a very skillful
servant, but every king he’s served has either
been insane or not caring about ruling. Varys
with this line basically strikes Daenerys with
a blunt hammer of truth and makes her realize
that he in fact is even more loyal to her
because he genuinely believes in her. As long
as she’s competent and is serving the realm,
then that in turn breeds unbreakable loyalty.
So to me, this is Varys’ best line in the
later seasons and I actually think this is
Varys’ last good scene in the show as well.
Number 1: “There’s always lessons in failures.
You must be very wise by now.” This may be a
little underwhelming if you were expecting
some kind of intellectual big IQ line,
but those fundamentally don’t exist in the later
seasons so I have to make do. But this line from
Olenna was such a genius and devastating insult
that it genuinely floored me. I think it’s by
far one of the most clever lines in seasons 7
and 8 and I think it easily cuts the deepest.
Just with these few words, she states how much
of a failure Jaime is and it’s also done with
a sarcastic twist of the line superficially
seeming like a compliment. A perfect line for
Olenna as a character that is more subtle
and communicated with a delicious amount
of sass. Also, this kind of insult isn’t as
bombastically annoying as a lot of other more
crude insults that David and Dan write. Like
I love The Hound’s spouting vitriolic insults,
but they normally lack creativity since David and
Dan just slap a couple curse words together. Or
Tyrion or Bronn says cock and starts laughing
as if they came up with comedy gold. So yeah,
this is my favorite line and you can probably
argue for the few lines before this being better,
but honestly, I don’t think really any of the
quote-on-quote intelligent lines are that good.
After going through all of seasons 7 and 8 I
thought there would be some better hidden gems,
but this was really the best that there
was. It’s really sad that there’s this
huge of a disparity in quality of
writing, probably because we're
dealing with a world-class writer and then
two mediocre screenwriters. But even then,
David and Dan had years to write these scripts
and had brilliantly complex characters at their
disposal. So I’m kind of surprised they couldn’t
write anything better for these characters. It
seems like a lot of dialogue is rushed into
just being used as a device to quickly move
the plot forward. Instead of a wonderful tool to
investigate these characters in great depth. God
damn what a disservice to these characters and us.
Thank you for watching and my letterboxd, patreon,
and discord link are in the description. And let
me know in the comments if I missed any lines from
the later seasons that you liked or what your
favorite is. Also thank you so much to Logan
Farmer for being a monumental patron and unlocking
tier of me shouting him out. Thank you so much.